today's national school walkout calls
attention to the issue of gun violence
in America's schools this morning our
series issues that matter looks at how
the safety debate and education issues
are playing out in classrooms with us
now are two of the nation's top
educators Johanna Hayes back at the
table she was a 2016 National Teacher of
the Year
you remember that day mrs. Hayes we sure
do she teaches social studies at John F
Kennedy High School in Waterbury
Connecticut and Shaun Sheehan is is
Oklahoma's 2016 Teacher of the Year he
now teaches algebra 1 at Louisville High
School
Harmon campus in Texas good morning it
may be fine had a teacher like you and
algebra I would have done a little bit
better miss you very good to have you
guys both back at the table could I get
your reaction to the student walkout
today what did you encourage your
students to take part do you think
students should be penalized if they do
take part well I'm so incredibly proud
of students who are participating in
this walkout and I don't think that it
was a matter of encouraging students to
take part in today's events I think just
as a history teacher as a social studies
teacher encouraging students to engage
in democracy that's something we do
every day so to see them on their own
decide that they wanted to elevate their
voices in this way I think we prepare
them with the tools to do it now to see
them practice that skill that's what any
teacher wants so I'm so I stand with
students I'm proud of students to
elevate their voices and be a part of
this conversation mr. Chan unfortunately
we're on spring break so participate but
I'm hoping that they'll continue the
momentum and stay active in this
conversation now both of your schools
received shooting threats after the
incident in parkland is this something
you deal with and think about every day
how do you handle something like that I
think of it regularly
I mean daily so I'm always running
through this scenario what if it is
shooter interest from this door the my
quickest exit is this way if I'm in the
classroom then I'm thinking about where
the nearest desk that I can pile in
front of this door to protect my
students I think thinking like I would
say over the last two years is when it
became more of a routine for me
I it's not something that I think about
that often I think that when kids are in
school that's teaching time you know
that's learning time and anything that
any time we're doing something other
than that then it's taking away from
time with students in the incident at
Kennedy High School the students were
the ones who brought it to the attention
of authorities
you've got the threat we got the threat
the students were the ones who saw
something you know on social media that
was troubling they brought it to the
attention of authorities and I think
that's what we're trying to teach them
how to do so to see them you know
respond in that way let's talk about
some of the solutions that have been
proposed or remedies Shawn the president
has said that he wants more school
personnel to carry firearms how do you
see that I think it's a terrible idea
and I'm coming from this from a point
where just two months ago I was at a gun
range in Lewisville Texas firing an
ar-15 I'm comfortable with guns I'm
comfortable weapons but they have no
place in the classroom you know teachers
we have a ever growing list of job
duties we should not add security guards
to that list of job responsibilities
yeah but what about those who say well
had a teacher been armed in parkland it
could have stopped the shooter well we
had someone who was armed and well
certified to address the situation and
he didn't unfortunately he didn't act
right I would make the case that it's
it's it's a it's a roll of the dice
and I think they're way more negatives
that would come along with it you were
at a shooting range with an ar-15
because you just wanted to see what it
was like or you're comfortable with guns
you like guns both yeah so I was with a
friend of mine who was formerly in law
enforcement and I wanted to see what the
what all the hype was about and then see
where you know why are so people
protecting these so viciously and I
think it's foolish I think we really do
need to revisit a ban on assault weapons
because those those have one purpose and
it's to kill and people don't need is
easy of access to them that they have
Johar let the CDC estimates that one in
five children experience a mental
disorder the president has talked about
that in Florida talked about improving
funds for mental health how do you see
that I think any improvement in mental
health it's something that we have
needed to address for a long time but I
see that as a larger societal issue you
know to talk about that as part of a
school safety policy I think just
distracts from what we should be talking
about you know allowing spaces for
students to learn in school keeping
students safe you know there are we have
social workers so how about we increase
the resources you know I'm in a school
in urban public school where every time
there's a budget cut we start to cut
resources to address things just like
you just said you know and even to your
last point your from your and I know
what you're saying I mean teachers know
how to teach I mean that's why there
were other social workers who are
supposed to address the problems that
Nick Cruz had down and back yeah my
husband is a detective we have guns in
our home you know but our roles are very
different we go to work to do very
different things you know I don't want
to carry a gun I want to stand in front
of kids I want to make sure that we
create a space for them to learn all of
these other things that are added on as
part of the conversation really confuse
what we're really talking about and
blurs the line between the roles shown
you moved to Texas from Oklahoma
teachers in Oklahoma that I think the
second lowest paid in the country how
explain for people how that pay I mean
it made you move you talked about the
growing list of duties explain the
tension and the lower pay and all those
extra duties sure so you know they like
to talk a lot about average salary so
first for perspective I have six years
of experience my master's degree had the
title of 2016 Oklahoma's Teacher of the
Year my take-home pay was eighteen
hundred dollars my rent was eleven
hundred my daycare cost was six so you
can do the math I'm a math teacher
that's not going to work out yeah we
were looking at just over oversized
classrooms a lack of resources over a
hundred school districts have gone to
four-day school weeks and so once we had
our daughter we welcomed our first child
we didn't want to subject our own family
to that that they're crumbling you know
infrastructure what do you think is a
teachers a good range of pay for
teachers from what to what I know it
varies but what do you think is a good
start either one of you it depends on
the state yeah all right and I think
that's part of the problem it's
municipal so it'd be like in Connecticut
a small state but from one end to the
other the variables are so different but
this is still a profession I worked
really hard to be a teacher I have a
graduate degree a postgraduate degree
really invested in this is a career
so there it the compensation needs to
match that great we agree with you right
we teachers do yeah Johanna Hayes and
Shan Shan thank you so much for joining
us we appreciate it